you are a product of your environment
you have to have those people around you
you can have Elon Musk and Mel Robbins
and Tony Robbins and whoever pushing you
every day you can have them pushing you
every
day by consuming their content we just
happen to be
enslaved
by the things that are around us that we
haven't designed with intention that's
all YouTube the algorithm is so
addictive you get one video that then
takes you down another path and another
path and all of a sudden you've just
watched 3 hours of videos on something
that doesn't make your life better and
you don't actually really care about you
just got sucked into the drama of a
certain storyline